Okay.
Shachar Peled, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
Happy to be ... wonderful.
As you can see in the Galilee right now,
so no complaints.
I love it.
Covid-19 is horrible, it's horrific,
and it's disturbing so many lives,
but I have to say that I am thankful
that I get to have people like you
on the show.
People that are so incredibly busy
in the day to day.
And your response to my request saying,
"Well I'm in quarantine,
so we might as well
because I have some time now."
So I want to thank you, first of all,
for being so generous with your time.
Shachar, I have so much to learn
over these next 20 minutes.
So, I'm really gonna go fast
and I'm gonna cram you with questions,
because there's just so many things
that I want to learn. First of all-
I'm used to being on the other side,
so I'm ready for your questions.
I love it.
Okay. So, you're a journalist
by profession now.
You said multimedia journalist.
So, you cover agnostically
all sorts of different industries.
You studied at Columbia University
after serving
in the elite intelligence unit in Israel.
Been with CNN, European Correspondent now
for Channel 13,
but you're also part of the launch team
for i24 News, right?
That's all true. Yes.
Amazing. Okay. So, I got that right.
But Shachar, now it's your turn.
Walk me back through your journey.
How do you transition
from being a researcher
in the intelligence units
to being a journalist?
Right.
So, it was actually a very,
it felt very natural the transition.
If you think about it,
being in intelligence is all about
working with sources and writing reports
and working with a tight knit
group of people.
And what I actually realized
I wanted to do is continue that story
in order to shed light on various issues,
but on a wider basis.
So, journalism was
a very very natural shift
from what I was doing in the military
and in the prime minister's office.
And I found myself, I was debating at 22
as most of us do in Israel,
debating what my path in life will be.
And I realized that storytelling
and doing it to wide audiences
and unearthing stories
that I've never heard about
and have this this wow element to them
but that more than 10 people
can read them
because they're not top secret
was what I was meant to do.
And I started pursuing that route.
So right after my studies,
I worked for Channel Two News
which was the largest,
and still is the largest,
commercial news channel in Israel.
From there,
I had the amazing opportunity
to be part of this media startup, i24 News
the first ever international,
multi-language channel in Israel.
I personally grew up,
my upbringing was in London.
So I had good English,
and this channel was looking for
English, native English speakers,
French speakers, and Arabic speakers.
So I could get this opportunity
to become an on-air correspondent
which I did for about three years.
And from then shifted on
to life in New York.
As you mentioned,
my master's in Columbia Journalism School
which was a ride in its own right.
A career in CNN,
both New York and in London.
Wow.
And now I'm usually based in Europe.
Right now, quarantined in Israel.
But this shift has been a roller coaster
and a wonderful ride.
Shachar, I want to learn a little bit more
about your take on this idea
that you're unearthing stories
within the IDF
and the prime minister's office.
You mentioned these are stories
that are read by 10 people.
And now you're shifting
to unearthing stories
that are going to be watched
by dozens of thousands,
if not hundreds of thousands.
So, talk to me about that shift.
And I want to hear a little bit about
your take on the responsibility
that you hold on unearthing these stories
because like we just talked
before we started,
I'm looking at the work that you're doing
and I'm saying,
Okay. Well, I'm watching you
cover this story.
You covered a story
of Eritreans in Israel, right?
With the protest back then.
And I watched that story
and it was phenomenal.
And then I kept thinking to myself like,
Wow. These were amazing five minutes.
I learned so much,
but there must be another thousand minutes
that I didn't hear about, right?
And you hold the responsibility
of choosing which five minutes to show.
So, talk to me a little bit
about that responsibility.
Right. So, I'll take you to a
quick glimpse of behind the scenes
of what's happening really when you do
either a print or digital story,
and definitely in broadcast.
There are hours and hours
of footage usually.
The more the merrier.
You want to try and make a deep dive
into anything, any story you encounter.
And one of the reasons
I became a journalist was to
every day learn new things.
And one day be in the kitchen
with this chef who's doing
these creative things,
and the other day being in a
terror act zone and covering
things that happen
that are breaking news.
And the shift from cultural to politics
to technology to social issues
is so wide and so vast
that I found it fascinating
and I still do until this very day.
And so I love doing
this deep dive into stories,
but you also have
a limited amount of time,
a limited amount of paper.
Digital not so much,
but today you still have to limit
the amount of words that you publish.
Especially for my generation.
The scrolling generation.
These are not one minute bites.
It's hard to capture attention.
And it's almost there's a conflict
of interest that's saying on one hand
I want to capture the attention
with a clickbait.
On the other end,
I want to be responsible
and say truthful information, right?
That's very true.
And what you want to do
is keep the essence of the story.
So, if I'm covering a protest of migrants
and asylum seekers
or if I'm doing a story
about this one specific artist,
I'm always looking
at what the message it is
that I'd like to convey
what the other person,
what the story that they're telling is.
And I've been very grateful
and thankful that I was able
to tell some stories
that actually create change.
And that's what I would like to do
personally, as a journalist.
There's this I guess
stigma of journalists being objective.
There's always this,
you can't put your feelings into things.
It's no longer ...
When I studied journalism
and I personally worked that way,
I always find that there's something
that I want to tell
and there's something
that needs to be changed,
and I want to be the one
to help change that.
And especially working for CNN
that was prominent
when we tell a story that then,
as you said,
hundreds and thousands of people can see.
We created change.
One of the stories I did
that I'm most proud of
is highlighting Holocaust survivors
that live in poverty in the US.
It's a very well-known
well covered issue in Israel
and it's being treated,
but in the United States of America,
the empire of capitalism,
if you're poor you're poor
and you need to lift yourself up.
But when we're talking
about Holocaust survivors,
most of them are over 80, 85 years old.
This was surprising to me
that they have no structure
and no some kind of institution
that is taking care of them
from the state,
from the federal level.
And after doing this story,
we've received multiple and multiple
calls from individuals,
from organizations,
from nonprofits who said,
"I want to lend a hand.
I want to help.
Can you connect me to these individuals.
I want to do something about this."
So, that's just one example of how you.
And I spent hours and hours
with these people,
but the essence was to tell
their very specific story
in order to get them help
or tell another story's ... awareness
or tell another story
that would create some kind of initiative.
These are all things
that I'm very passionate about.
And how do you even uncover these stories?
So, growing up as an Israeli in Tel Aviv
and now in the Bay Area,
I have family that perished
in the Holocaust.
And I am very versed in the history of it,
but I never even stopped to think that,
yes, in the US also
we have Holocaust survivors
that don't have the structure
in this capitalist society
that Israel provides,
or is aiming to provide, currently
to Holocaust survivors.
How do you go about
unearthing these stories
and really understanding their value?
Because, I mean,
part of the idea here is
that you are unearthing things
that are not mainstream, right?
Right.
And I was actually very fortunate
to be the outsider
when I was working in the CNN newsroom
in New York specifically.
I was the only Israeli,
actually, I was the only foreigner.
Everyone there was American,
and our specific department
was about 50, 60 people.
And that actually allowed me to be
sort of the one that brings in
these alternative stories.
Things that others didn't look at.
And it was actually an amazing time.
It was at the height of the
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump campaigns.
And there was a lot of focus
on xenophobia, on the other,
on immigrants, on asylum seekers.
And in addition to that
being a fascinating topic for me,
I also found myself ... that
were different from the regular mindset.
And because CNN allowed me
this amazing opportunity to just,
here's a camera,
go out and explore Boise, Idaho,
and Baton Rouge, Louisiana,
and all these places I've never heard of.
And suddenly had this opportunity
to cover the campaigns there
and how people were reacting.
There was this whole issue
with North Korea, obviously.
And then we started interviewing
North Korean asylum seekers in the US,
which was fascinating.
And it was only because, I think,
I was the outsider that I was looking
for these outsider stories.
So that was a great opportunity.
That's just incredible.
And I mean, are there specific things
that you're particularly excited about
as you go about
Is it the filming of it, the interviewing,
the research in the computer?
Or is it the post-production
helping the editors
put the story together?
Which part of it are you most excited?
Oh, that's like choosing
between mom and dad.
Well especially in
the past couple of years
when I've been really
just a one woman band.
I've been the correspondent,
the photographer, the researcher,
the producer.
It's unfortunately and fortunately only me.
So, I'll give you an example.
We were in Paris
when the Notre Dame caught on fire
and obviously it was a historic
and devastating moment.
And at that point, obviously,
it's just me. By chance
I was with my tripod and camera with me,
and what I needed to do at that moment
... news and I'm on air all the time,
I had to do this combination
of filming myself, reaching out
and asking people and the police,
women and men that were there
what was going on.
Interviewing, being in touch
with the control room.
These are all things that the producer,
the camera person does,
the researcher does
and the reporter usually do.
Thankfully, my husband was there
to help me carry around the tripod
here and there.
But most of these things
I do by myself. And I love it.
There's a lot of adrenaline,
but I also will admit
it's a big challenge.
Sometimes I'm so exhausted
by the end of the day
that I'm asking myself,
"Why do I do this?"
But then the following day comes
and there's another story to cover.
To me, it sounds like
you're ready to transition from this
to running the control room
for a NASA launch,
because it doesn't sound too different
at this point.
By all means,
just give me the control panel.
I'll take care of everything.
How long does it take from the moment
that you understand that there is
some potential for something.
Yeah. There might be something in Arkansas
that we might want to cover,
this is interesting, to the moment
where it actually gets aired
to millions of viewers on CNN
and you get the message across.
How long does that process take?
It really depends.
So, if you're talking about CNN, again,
it's a huge, well oiled machine.
They have the resources
to just say even, "We're not sure
there's a story there,
Bbt here are plane tickets,
or a train ride, or a car,
or the accommodation that you need
to ... there's a story there"
There was one sort of murder mystery I did
driving for like five days through
it was Connecticut, Massachusetts,
I think a few states there
on the northeastern part of the US
just to try and chase a story
and see if there's bulk
and anything that we can
actually create content from.
So, it really depends.
And this was from one day to the next.
Just Shachar, are you ready on Tuesday
to take the car and just go on a road trip
around these states
to see if there's a story.
Others, you know, it might take time
if we have time to plan ahead
and see in advance if we can do
one story or another
then we do the planning.
Most of the time, it's not even
from one day to the next.
Now, with Channel 13,
as you know in Israel,
everything's last minute,
and we can sometimes decide
from one hour to the next
that I'm on this flight to Germany
to cover a story or wherever I need
to be across Europe.
It sounds exhausting
and exhilarating at the same time.
Absolutely. Yeah, that's true.
No, no that's just incredible.
And looking down at how now you operate
in different places.
And I'm really curious to hear your take
on the transition of journalism
to the different generations.
And I'm even looking at my nieces
who are now a few days old,
three years, and six years old,
and the way that
they're consuming information,
not necessarily news, but any information
is drastically different than the way
that I'm even consuming it.
And so, I'd love to hear a little bit
about your take on
how journalism is changing and adapting
to the younger generations.
And I believe you asked this question
to the person who ran the BBC News
right?
And so I'm especially curious
to hear your answer.
Well you did your research.
I have ... with a journalist.
I had to prepare a little bit.
Right. Very true.
I'm very impressed.
So, you know the phrase
from Pixar's Ratatouille,
"Everyone can be a chef"
or "Everyone can be a cook."
These days, I feel like
everyone can be a journalist.
You need the basic tools
and obviously some experience,
but with the platforms that exist today
to reach everyone and anyone at any time.
It's also the danger
and we can spend hours
talking about misinformation
and disinformation,
but it's also an amazing opportunity
to spread stories
and reach so many people
so very quickly.
And I look at myself today.
I consume news mostly from social media.
And I'm not talking only about
Facebook or places where you can
add a lot of text and explain the story.
Instagram today, Twitter,
even TikTok these days,
you can learn so much from these platforms
in terms of, just even getting
a new initiative or inspiration
from seeing someone
doing things and saying,
"Hey, that's new." or
"I've never heard or seen anyone
do that thing before
or ask those questions before"
And want to do a story from that
or get information from that.
And I think anyone
who's serious today in news
has presence in all of these platforms,
because that's where we get the news
and this is a way
to spread news as well.
So without a doubt, social media,
TV still exists as as does radio.
I can't say that much about print,
but everything that has to do
with social media today
and the platforms know it.
Facebook, Amazon, Apple, Google,
all the big digital giants
they know that
that's where people consume their news
and their information.
And that's what they do.
They are now putting more and more focus
on how do you stop misinformation
and become a truthful,
justifiable news platform.
Right. So, I agree.
I mean we can talk for hours
about the dangers of misinformation
and fake news that come
with the democratization
of dissemination of information.
But what I'm especially curious is,
do you believe that 10 years
or 15 years from now,
we will need reporters
to be in front of the Notre Dame
in case something happens?
Or is it enough that we'll have people
holding whatever device they'll use
if it won't be already in our glasses
and talk while they're watching it?
Is there still room
for in-field journalism in 10, 15 years
if I become a journalist
simply by the virtue of me having a phone?
I actually thought
that you were about to ask me
...
and for that I have a very quick answer.
But for what you are asking,
... because your question is more interesting.
So start with the robots ones.
Well with robots,
what we can see today is that,
even with the basic levels of AI
that we have today,
it's not giving us stories.
When I go to YouTube,
and even if you make it better
and the aggregation of information
will be better,
then you won't get the levels of depth
and investigation that you want
from what currently AI can do.
And I don't see that improving
in 10 years.
We can talk about 50,
but to answer your question.
I think that yes,
anyone can become a journalist,
but you have to have the
I think, still, it's all about trust.
So you have to have the backing
and the the support of some kind of system
that people trust.
So, you can be an individual
and start reporting
and if what you are unveiling
is found to be truthful, interesting,
new, all the basics
and the fundamentals of news,
of course you can become a journalist.
It's all about practice
and experience of how to ask
the right questions and how to address.
You need that.
But very much so in journalism,
it's on job training.
And I'm saying that as someone
who has a master's in journalism.
Most of what I do right today
is not from school;
it's from being in the field.
And I think yes,
an individual can do that,
but it's obviously helpful
when you have The New York Times
or The New Yorker or
The Washington ... behind you
as not only a support system,
but as a way of others to trust you.
So I think in 10 years,
that would still be the case.
Shachar, this was inspiring,
and I learned so much
over these past 20 minutes.
I want to thank you again
for being so generous with your time.
Before we finish,
I have to ask you
the most important question:
Three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Right.
So, I thought very hard on that question
'cause it's very very difficult.
So I guess the first,
which is a new word for me,
would be mother
since I have a six month old sunshine.
So and it's not only mother
it's, if I cheat a bit,
it's being a family person.
A family woman
'cause it's my dear dear husband,
my partner and my son who are now
definitely defining myself and my life.
The second word would be storyteller,
and I don't need to elaborate on that.
I think we've done that for 20 minutes now.
And the third, what was the third?
I think it's difficult
'cause it's trying to describe myself.
But it could be,
I don't want to cheat.
It could be anything from being
I'll let you cheat a little bit.
Okay. Thank you.
So, anything from being multidisciplinary
to just being honest.
An honest person.
Sometimes it's good
and sometimes it's a bit bad,
but I guess that describes me best.
Shachar, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
This was inspiring. Enjoy the quarantine.
I see that throughout the filming
of this episode, it got dark over there.
Oh, it did. You're right.
But thank you very very much,
and I look forward
to continue seeing the stories
that you unfold.
Thank you so much.
It was wonderful.
Bye.